ciao maria verzé benvenuti di un
nuovissimo viviamo come vedete oggi sono
vestite in maniera un po particolare
molto poco sobria perché rappresenta un
personaggio oggi ho voluto farvi vedere
la differenza tra le mamme di una volta
e alle mamme di oggi e questa
chiaramente non è la mamma di una volta
quindi buona visione ci vediamo alla
fine del video
[Applauso]
mamma posso andare alla festa di giulia
no ma per cano ci saranno tutti i miei
compagni
senti calotta a me non interessa che ci
solito accompagna la festa in discoteca
non ci puoi andare fino a quando vivrai
sotto questo tempo in discoteca non ci
fai petto e pericoloso ma perché perché
ho deciso così pompa sta migliorando
io posso bue ma stasera vado una festa
di chi giulia degli amici con più gli
anni ma dov'è lontano ci circonda
chilometri ma è dai vicino e come ci vai
fini ma un passaggio lo trovo work
maggiorenne decisero attenzione o ti
devo mandare questo viene che fa il
liberissimo c'è troppo divertente
ciao amore di let it
[Applauso]
professore guardi al mio permesso per
sfidarla davanti a tutta la classe
perché lo deve capire è se il caso
prendete anche dei seri provvedimenti
sospendete la lo deve capire che non ci
si deve comportare così e fedele
studiare se vuole passare l'anno
io guardi che lo ricolo già messa in
punizione non può più uscire o può più
fare niente finché non si comporta come
si deve sto abituando il mio polso i fan
di sarah la nonna di carlotta parlo con
il maestro d'italiano
si va detto fissore quello che è senta
la devi smettere di dare questi molti
passi a mia figlia perché veramente in
occhio lo merita perché mia figlia
studia tutti i giorni proprio adesso
guardi sta studiando la vedo con i miei
occhi è quindi inaccettabile va bene e
sto pagando alte scuole perché la voglio
togliere da quella quasi vintage atti la
figlia e stressate non ha neanche più in
discoteca ma si rende conto
[Applauso]
cosa vi devo mandare che ha capito
niente ci deve essere stato un
interferenza maletto di mandargli un
insomma ma che cosa è un codice della
banca mamma è un messaggio come ce lo
mando questo messaggio col telefono con
questa cosa qua messo confondendo per
favore a farlo dopo anno tour
questa tecnologia me dalla testa sta
mediando il mio posto
[Musica]
no
mamma ma a 45 anni fa il musical in sei
patetica ma sarai tu patetica aiuto già
4 mila follower e comunque sommativa
giovanile me lo dicono i miei fan di 8
anni che non li dimostro
[Applauso]
mamma ho fame cose da mangiare
amore di mamma ha cucinato tutto il
giorno per te che ho preparato la pasta
al forno alla parmigiana gli involtini
di pesce spada il capo progetto e patate
e anche la caponata sembra fame non
finisce vi faccio sentire ci siano due
minuti
[Musica]
stando al mio posto
ma cosa c'è per cena ma come persona
l'amore non deve diventare da sua nonna
no ti prego non mi fa cucinare che sono
a diete poi mi viene fame se ti fai così
ordinati una pizza su quelle
applicheranno di modo adesso è anche c'è
la mia carta te la pago io va bene ciao
amore brava cia
[Applauso]
come ti chiami elisabetta che lavoro
fanno i due genitori e mio papà è il
postino ti stai facendo la differenza mi
numeri no o meno no tu no mai la
continuità cioè la faccio la giocata e
da spari chat e caricate vai subito via
perché io mia figlia con la faccia
guardare dalle disagiata sta abituando
il mio posto e senti un po manifestare
in musica in certo 20 mila follower no
vabbè ordinati adorerà quando può
iniziare
[Applauso]
carlotta ai di nuovo preso tra in
matematica
io non te lo dico più può adesso fa in
punizione a vita le vacanze non le fai
sia in camere e non esci tu con le toni
che non le vedrai mai più per tutta la
vita ti mette a studiare sta abituando
rimossa carlo in amia note ne ha
chiamato da scuola abbiamo detto che
ieri non sei andata doveri alla spinta
di gucci tutta sua madre vabbè dai rami
telefono mezz'ora senza instagram tipo
bastare come punizione
[Applauso]
mamma io esco carlotta valico ti fa
impazzire puoi fare morire mi pare volti
subito a cambiare se tutto hanno dai 13
anni dal corano di civiltà la bambina 6
cambiati o pd ma le gambe
[Musica]
sta migliorando di agosto la mamma come
sto amore ma dove devi andare combinata
così che cos'è questo pantaloncino cioè
fai vedere un po le gambe dai io ti ho
fatto così carina scopri che un po 20
giu di quei vestitini che ti ho comprato
quelli venire da combattimento nobile
andare a ballare levi baccagliare e
magari tuttavia ex fidanzatino sarebbe
anche loro amore no mai ai nar gli archi
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che il video vi
sia piaciuto fatemi sapere insomma se
ritrovate nelle vostre mamme in una di
queste due tipologie e come al solito se
non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
canale e cliccate sulla campanella che
trovate vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per
rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti i
modi video ma soprattutto per essere i
primi a commentare
ricordatevi anche di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social instagram facebook e
music hall mando un bacione ci vediamo
al prossimo video adoro